So today we're going to talk about, what if the universe is just a computer simulation
How would we know? What sort of things wont we expect to see? Could we ever tell; Could we ever be able to work out that we're you know, living part of a simulation. Of we're just bits of information
courses The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy where for example the earth was
just massive computer program and all
the people on it form part of how did
they put it the organic matrix does the
matrix of course itself which is a
really really intriguing idea really
intelligent concept let down by some the
earth or acting it's a fascinating
concept for anybody are we living in a
simulation and it stretches all the way
back it's a philosophical a thorny
philosophical issue so there's a whole
sort of subfield of physics now called
digital physics where physicists and
computer scientists are getting together
and the idea is that the fundamental
basis of reality the fundamental basis
of physics is not energy it's not matter
its information and there's a guy called
John Wheeler back in the 70s that is
wonderful phrase called it from bit the
most fundamental aspect of our reality
is information this is physics world
back in just last year modeling our
universe is a giant computer and the
idea here is that instead of having
what's called continuous functions
instead of being able to basically pick
any particular point in space no matter
how small the smallest infinitesimal
there's a quantization space is divided
up into chunks or space is divided into
a grid and that's really reminiscent of
things that were happening again back in
the 70s but have been you know obviously
developments in the decades since then
where the something called Conway's Game
of Life which is a really really neat
example of how simple rules very simple
rules can give rise to complexity and
what you do is you set up a grid it
could be in three dimensions but
generally in Conway's Game of Life we
consider two dimensions and what you do
is something really really simple really
simple rules right what we're going to
do is we're going to populate this grid
so we have squares which are like little
animals and one and those really simple
rules what you basically see so you
start off your system and what you're
going to do is each time round we get a
computer
but there's no reason if you were
suitably inclined and had nothing better
to do with your life that you couldn't
do with just pen and paper you look at
this one you look at each animal or each
cell let's call them cells in the grid
and you say look at the many neighbors
it's got and then you have very simple
rules if it's got zero or one neighbors
it dies out of loneliness if it's got
more than four neighbors it dies out of
overpopulation overcrowding and if it's
got two or three then it's happy so
that's those those one set of rules if
it's occupied if it's not occupied if it
doesn't have a cell in it then what
happens is that if it's got three
neighbors so here for example then what
will happen is this one will become live
if you do this I'll show you the screen
this ISM obviously it's going to take a
long time if we were to do that with pen
and paper
Giancarlo's game of life by a guy called
where is it Martin Edwin Martin so what
you do is let's take a really simple one
like that and what we're going to do is
we're going to play those rules and
watch what happens you might think oh
this is going to be fairly boring book
so you get something which is called a
glider just due to the way those those
rules work okay so in this case once it
reaches the edge of the grip the edge of
the grid things effectively stop so
let's do this one and let's see what
happens now Wow remember how basic yours
rules are my daughterís of seven and
nine my sons actually fought I could
explain those rules to him and see what
you got there this case it reaches a
steady stay at a boring steady state but
before let's run that again it's all
that complexity just from very basic
rules stop it again and then or we can
do something completely random let's
clear it Edwin's provided the facility
to do need things like this that's a
very wonky face and then we run this
same rules and what you see is the
population so this is I hope you can see
how its way it's called game of life now
and in the 70s you know this was
paradise for geeks you know this was
steer to the art computer graphics in
the 70s in fact I my computing started
in the eighties with something called
the zx81 this isn't color
this is far beyond what I was capable of
back in 1981 so on this would have been
heaven for me but notice so in this case
this once keeps flicking around and it
will do that for infinity but what's
remarkable here is unbelievably simple
rules on a grid on this type of grid
give rise to this type of complexity and
what's the important thing here well
it's the information it's the the fact
that this this animal or this whatever
you want to call it sell at this
position is affected by its influence by
its neighbors and it's the it's those
interactions and how that information is
exchanged that gives rise to this level
of complexity and physicists in all
seriousness not all of not all
physicists are allowed to certainly
admit that there's a large number who
would seriously doubt this and would
argue that actually at the most
fundamental level space-time reality
amongst us around us is not a grid like
this it is not quantized but computer
scientists physicists a large number of
those are arguing well actually no it
may well be like this and then it
becomes very very interesting indeed as
to how these basically these rules play
out so what this has got to do with you
and me and atoms and galaxies is that
the important thing here is if the
system depends just solely on well
weather is this unit is this grid
occupied or not is that a 1 or a 0 is
that a bit or is it not a bit then do we
treat particle interactions like that
digital physics is reasonably well
developed there are it has its
proponents it has its opponents but the
idea that spaced I might be quantized
what are the zeros and ones what's the
equivalent like are you talking about
like atoms of the bits or is it more
fundament it's not as the fundamental
particles it's the idea that right at
the very limit of a very smallest thing
you can imagine like the Planck length
at that level we're talking we're seeing
that that space is quantized you know
these are ones and zeroes if it's
occupied it's a 1 if it's not occupied
it's a zero and what's the equivalent of
occupied and unoccupied at the quantum
in the presence for example the presence
of a particle the absence of a particle
what slightly more left to field and
slightly more off-the-wall but
nonetheless interesting is could we be
actually the result of a computer
simulation by some super hyper
dimensional or whatever set of aliens or
indeed future generations could we be
living in future and there's a guy
called Nick Bostrom at Oxford at the
future of humanity Institute in Oxford
who's proposed something called a
simulation argument who argues this
you've got three options first of all
one is that we'd go extinct we don't
reach we saw at some point we blow
ourselves of global warming comes along
and we wipe ourselves out relatively
boring steady-state second one is that
what okay we get lots and lots of
technology but we just sort of lose
interest in for example trying to run
simulations at larger and larger and
larger simulations but the third one and
the third one is the most interesting
one is well we develop better and better
technology and what that technology
allows us to do is you run better and
better simulations up to the point where
we can simulate an entire universe if
you can simulate an entire universe and
if really what matters right at the
bottom end of this is whether you fill a
grid with ones and zeros that's
computing then and if our consciousness
and our sentience stems from that then
what you'll do is you create sentient
beings in a supercomputer or so and the
argument is that if you do have that
type of technological capability of
Bostrom's argument is that it's
exceedingly likely if we do progress to
that point that we are in a simulation
this is not reality this is a simulated
real life and you can think of layers
upon layers upon layers of simulations
and how would we ever know we'd like to
thank audible.com for its support of
this computer file video audible has a
massive range of audio books and if
you're someone like me who has to go on
a lot of long drives or walk the dog
every day it's great being able to catch
up with books on a portable device like
your iPhone - recommendations after a
video like this Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy and also fineman's
physics lectures and the good thing
about these two is you can actually
listen to the guys who wrote the books
Fineman himself and douglas adams which
is always a nice trait hearing their
voices you can download a free audio
book at audible comm slash computer file
so go and check it out and thanks to
audible for supporting channels like
this it's great for us to be able to
team up with a company that's selling
books and information and also a company
that kind of uses technology and things
like that things we love here at
computerphile
so while you go and get free audiobook
I'm going to get this thing rolling well
that's a nice one